c'est un message d'espoir et de soutien
aux personnes victimes je leur dire
qu'elles ont été entendus et que le
changement de culture t'en réclamé
allait devenir réalité une promesse du
ministre de la justice il y a un an le
tout premier tribunal spécialisé en
matière de violence sexuelle et
conjugale était lancée à sa la mairie de
Valleyfield on compte aujourd'hui 10
projets pilotes dans la province c'était
le temps qu'on s'y attarde je constate
qu'on a fait des pas énormes dans le
système judiciaire des pas de géant je
dirais même un examen de conscience
était nécessaire mais le défi colossal
et mobilise d'importantes ressources des
choses se mettent en place
tranquillement mieux vaut agir ne
faisant pas trop de d'erreurs pour être
obligé de reculer on reste en fait avec
le même vieux système avec un nouvel
emballage ce qui est proposé ne répond
pas aux besoins des victimes selon cette
militante il y a un sentiment finalement
d'un goût amer parce que certaines
survivants se rendent compte finalement
qu'on leur a vendu un système qui
finalement est encore en contradiction
avec les besoins des victimes la loi ne
change pas le projet pilote prévoit de
la formation un meilleur accompagnement
des victimes et l'aménagement des palais
de justice notamment mais il y a peu
d'alternatives au système de justice
traditionnel les personnes qui veulent
pas une somme d'argent qui veulent pas
une peine de prison mais qui veulent des
excuses qui veulent une forme de
réparation ces personnes-là en ce moment
vont continuer de dénoncer à l'extérieur
des postes de police tente et aussi
longtemps qu'il y aura pas une forme de
justice institutionnelle qui comprend
puis qui tiennent compte de leurs
besoins il faudra du temps avant de
savoir ce qu'on pense les victimes
traverser le processus judiciaire et
long métaux sont d'avis qu'on doit
poursuivre la discussion parfait on a
peut-être fait des pas mais à la fin de
la journée ce n'est pas ça qui va faire
un changement de culture et encore moins
qui va rebâtir la confiance des victimes
à la gare du système de justice autre
défi la formation des juges elle est
déjà obligatoire pour les nouveaux
magistrats mais pas pour ceux déjà en
exercice et encore du chemin à faire
pour que les jus soient mieux outils
pour comprendre les violences sexuelles
les violences conjugales ça va prendre
plusieurs années le avant que l'ensemble
des justiciers et bénéficier des
formations des tribunaux spécialisés le
projet pilote de tribunal spécialisé se
termine l'an prochain il doit ensuite
être implanté par l'ensemble du Québec
d'ici 2026 ici qui me permettra de
Canada Montréal